DANIEL FRIEDMAN: Hello and welcome.
Daniel: It's June 19, 2023.
We're going to have a presentation and a
discussion with Maxwell Ramstead and
Mahault Albarracin here.
So thank you, Maxwell and Mahault, for
joining.
Looking forward to your presentation,
setting some of the context, and then
thank you to all of our guests.
You'll have an opportunity to introduce
yourself and give some background when
you first give reflections.
So on to the slides.
Maxwell.
MAXWELL RAMSTEAD: Excellent.
Maxwell: Well, maybe now and I can just
briefly reintroduce ourselves for those
of us watching at home.
So, hey, folks, my name is Maxwell
Ramstead.
I am the director of Research versus AI.
I am a scholar in the tradition of active
inference and an expert on the Free
Energy Principle.
Yeah.
And Mahault,
would you please?
MAHAULT ALBARRACIN: Sure.
Mahault: So.
My name is Mahault Albarracin.
I work at Versus with Maxwell.
I'm Director of Product for Research and
development, but I'm also doing a PhD in
cognitive computing.
I worked in social sciences and in
artificial intelligence in the artificial
intelligence field.
And I've specifically tried to apply
active inference to more socially
grounded questions and sometimes more
abstract and representational questions,
diving all the way down to the philosophy
that can be attached to it.
Maxwell: Thank you, Mal.
So, yeah, I'm very pleased to present
this work.
Today, Mao and I will be discussing our
new preprint called the Inner Screen
Model of Consciousness.
And it is about basically an application
of the Free Energy Principle to the
problem, the conundrum of consciousness.
So just to give a little bit of
background and now I'll just be walking
through the slides, if at any point you
want to jump in and add complete correct,
please feel free to do so.
This is work that started in late last
year and continued throughout the year.
It's preoccupied us quite a bit, actually,
, over the last while.
Mao and I are the lead authors on this,
what has now become a series of papers,
with one more preprint coming out,
hopefully before the end of the month,
and another in the works, hopefully
before the end of the year, with the same
core group of authors.
So obviously Mao, as well as Adam Saffron,
, Alex Keefer, Brendan Klein, Chris
Fields and Karl Friston.
And the follow up papers include a bunch
of other authors.
So we've been working with some pretty
cool folks on this, folks listed here and
others.
Yeah.
So the overall aim across the two or
three papers is to present something like
a minimal, unifying model of
consciousness premised on the Free Energy
Principle.
In the paper that we're discussing today,
we are presenting, as I was intimating a
moment ago, a model of consciousness that
follows directly from applying the Free
Energy Principle to well understood human
neurophysiology.
The take home message of today's talk is
that, well, let me take one step back.
There has been a lot of discussion in the
literature over the last decade about
whether the Free Energy Principle has
anything unique to teach us about
consciousness.
And there have been responses pro and
contra.
And I think that the question up until
recently was just unsettled.
We would like to suggest a positive
response to that question.
And as such, one of the take home
messages is that actually, yes, a model
of consciousness can be directly derived
from the Free Energy Principle applied to
explain known neuroanatomy.
And I guess the kind of technical message,
, the technical part of the takeaway is
that consciousness has or is isomorphic
to a nested holographic mathematical
structure.
So this sounds like a mouthful, might
sound a little crazy.
We are going to unpack this presently.
Now, did you want to add anything to
that?
Mahault: No, all good.
Maxwell: Excellent.
So the original paper that we wrote
turned into, like a 24,000 word
monstrosity of a paper, and it was
elephantine both in the sense that it was
very large and also in the sense that of
the soupy parable of the blind men and
the elephant.
What we're trying to do is in some sense,
identify a parsimonious mathematical
structure that underwrites the different
accounts of consciousness that have been
developed based on the Free Energy
Principle.
I'll spare you the original paper
structure.
I said a moment ago that we were
developing a minimal unifying model.
This is a notion that was proposed by our
friend and colleague Vanya Visa, I
believe, a few years ago now, in 2020.
And Vanya at the time was noticing, well,
the field of consciousness studies is
replete with a bunch of different models
and theories, and there seems to be no
end in sight to the multiplication of
these theories.
And the idea is maybe what the field
needs is not one additional N plus one
theory of consciousness, but rather a
minimal unifying model by which Vanya
means a model that specifies only
necessary properties of consciousness.
So this doesn't come with, like, a strong
sufficiency claim, really, like, what are
the kind of rudimentary building blocks
that are necessary for consciousness in
general.
This model would have determinable
descriptions that can be made more
specific.
So it's kind of a base model that can be
expanded to cover different varieties of
conscious experience.
And finally, that it's minimal and
unifying in the sense that it integrates
current approaches to consciousness in no
small part by highlighting their common
assumptions.
So kind of pointing to a least common
denominator of all existing accounts.
And so what we have tried to do in this
paper is to well, in this series of
papers is to engage in this analysis and
this mummy analysis, if you will, for
theories of consciousness premised on the
Free Energy Principle directly.
So it's worth quickly discussing the Free
Energy Principle.
I'm almost embarrassed to do this at the
Active Inference Institute, but it's
always worth going through this very
quickly.
So there's a standard distinction in
physics that one can leverage between
dynamics, mechanics and principles.
The Free Energy Principle, as it says on
the tin is a principle.
So principles are kind of the foundation
of a hierarchy of theory building in
science, as it were.
Top of the hierarchy are formal
descriptions of behavior what are known
as dynamics.
So if you're applying dynamical systems
theory to understand the time evolution
of some system, you're in the realm of
dynamics.
Arguably, folks like Kepler and Galileo
were also in the realm of dynamics.
So I see some empirical phenomenon and I
produce a formal description of that
behavior.
Mechanics comes into play when we move
from Kepler and Galileo to Newton, when
we move from merely describing some
behavior to providing equations of motion
that allow us to explain why that
behavior has the particular shape that it
does.
So classical mechanics, for example,
gives us an account of gravitational
force and explains why orbits are shaped
the way they do.
So if galileo and kepler just noticed the
shape of orbits and provided a formal
description of them, newton explains
where that shape comes from in some sense,
, and principles, in turn, explain where
mechanics come from.
So classical mechanics come from the
principle of least action or stationary
action, which, very roughly speaking, is
the principle according to which no more
or no less energy is used than necessary
to perform some physical movements.
That kinetic.
And potential energies balance out such
that the true paths of a system through
its state space are those for which that
balance equals zero.
The principle of least action explains
where classical mechanics comes from.
In some sense.
And similarly, the Free Energy Principle
is at the basis of another kind of
mechanics that is becoming known as
Bayesian mechanics.
You can think of the Free Energy
Principle as having the same relation to
Bayesian mechanics as the principle of
least action has to classical mechanics.
And Bayesian mechanics is the physics of
probabilistic beliefs.
So it's a physics that connects the
properties of the system that you're
considering the physical properties of
the system.
In particular, the information entropy of
states of a system to the connects the
thermodynamic entropy of the states of a
system to the information entropy of the
beliefs that a system has about the
systems to which it is coupled.
Here.
A probabilistic belief means a
probability density in a very general
sense.
We're not assuming some kind of
contentful motion of belief like you
might find in philosophy.
Really.
This is about kind of a tracking relation.
.
But we'll get that to that in actually,
just a few slides.
There are two main formulations of the
Free Energy Principle in the literature.
The classical and the quantum.
Both rest on this apparatus of the Markov
blanket.
The Markov blanket definitionally is the
degrees of freedom that separate.
But couple two systems.
Or rather, two things within a larger
system.
It's effectively a statistical boundary
that allows us to say that, well, given
this boundary, the inside is independent
of the outside.
The way that we express the dependencies.
.
So taking one step back quickly, this is
a dynamic systems approach to cognition,
to self organizing systems, and to
physical systems more generally.
It is a dynamical systems approach in the
sense that we're using the tools of
dynamical systems theory to examine the
time evolution of a system, its
trajectory in its state space.
And in this context, a generative model
is used to encode the relations of
dependence that obtain in the time
evolution of the system.
So this is important and I've been kind
of making this point maybe ad nauseam for
the last, I guess, half decade.
But the generative model is not a model
that you have in your head.
It is a statistical model that represents
the conditional dependence structure of
the entire system that you're considering.
.
So this is an environment agent system in
the broadest sense.
And the Free Energy Principle says that
if a specific sparseness structure
obtains so if things are disconnected in
a special way, then it'll look as if the
subsets that are disconnected are
tracking each other.
So more technically, we partition our
system into particles.
Particles are basically internal states
shrouded behind their Markov blanket,
where the Markov blanket is composed of
sensory states and active states.
Sensory states affect internal states but
are not affected by internal states and
active states affect external states but
are not affected by external states.
This separation of causal dependence and
this structure intervening between the
two bulk subsets of the system is really
critical.
The Free Energy Principle says if my
generative model, which encodes all of
the dependencies of the system, if my
generative model contains a Markov
blanket in the sense that we just defined,
, then we are basically licensed in our
interpretation of internal states as
basically tracking external states where
tracking has a specific mathematical
definition.
In this context, tracking means to encode
the parameters of some probabilistic
belief about external states.
So to the extent that we want to call
this representation, we should note that
this is not a representation in the
typical tele semantic sense of having
some internal states track some external
features.
What we're saying is that basically if I
have a Markov blanket, then my internal
states are basically shaping a belief
about the external world.
And I think that's really critical to
understand.
And this is where the inference and the
modeling bit comes from.
This kind of tracking relationship,
formally speaking, is approximate daisy
and inference.
So basically, in a nutshell, the Free
Energy Principle says in our physical
universe as we understand it, with the
usual mechanics running in the background,
, right?
Classical relativistic, quantum and
statistical, if boundaries exist in the
physical system, then the bulk across the
boundary is going to be tracking whatever
is beyond the boundary.
So in a nutshell, this is what the Free
Energy Principle says.
Now, I noticed you put some stuff in the
chat.
Would you mind using your voice to
compliment.
Mahault: Yeah, I was just saying that
this part that you were just explaining
often seems kind of esoteric to people.
But it's critical to understand the
sparseness of the coupling because then
you kind of start understanding where
perspective comes from.
And if you have perspective, you also
have the capacity to assess causality
starting from a point and extending
outwards to something else.
And this is true from any so that's what
I wanted to add.
Maxwell: Thank you, Mala.
I think that's useful addition.
Yeah.
So this is the classical formulation of
the Free Energy Principle.
There is a new hip funky formulation that
has become available over the last half
decade due to Chris Fields, Jim
Glazebrook and their colleagues, the so
called quantum information theoretic
formulation of the FEP.
Fear not.
This doesn't appeal directly to quantum
mechanics.
Rather, it appeals to the tools that have
been used to extend information theory in
the context of quantum mechanics, which
allow you to calculate like all sorts of
funky wave equations and propagation
operators and all that.
We don't have to get into the details.
Basically, it's just a way to reframe
what I just said.
So what I just said is if there's a
boundary in my physical system, then the
things across the boundary will look as
if they're tracking each other.
Another way of saying that is, well, this
boundary is a kind of screen green takes
on a particular sense in quantum
information theory.
We don't necessarily have to get into the
details of it, but basically you can
think of these degrees of freedom that
couple the two systems as a kind of
probabilistic surface and you can think
of the bulk across either side of the
boundary as in alternation reading and
writing information onto the blanket.
So any Markov blanket whatsoever can be
construed as a classical information
channel or a screen and in effect, all of
the classical information that you need
to describe the way that things across
the boundary.
So the so called bulk of the system,
couple to one another, is contained on
the boundary.
It encodes the classical information that'
's necessary to describe the couplings
within the system.
This is holography.
This is the hologram.
Not in the sense of Holography.
Although we might discuss senses in which
these things are intertwined, we're using
the word Hologram in the sense of the
Holographic principle from physics.
The Holographic principle is a principle
that was originally discovered in the
context of black hole thermodynamics.
And what it basically tells us is
necessarily from the point of view of an
external observer.
Some bulk in physical space can only
contain as much information as can fit
onto its surface.
So this echoes what we were just
discussing about Markov blanket.
The physical reason is that if a bulk
collapses into a black hole and the bulk
contained any more information than could
be fit onto its boundary then we would
basically be losing information.
And that would violate the conservation
of classical information also known as
the principle of unitarity in quantum
mechanics which basically says that
information is never lost.
So we're using the word Hologram in that
sense.
This is different from the sense of
Hologram everyone has seen, like the
Hologram of Tupac.
Or does that make me look seem old at the
Super Bowl a few years ago?
Or maybe Pokemon cards, maybe that also
makes me seem old now.
I don't know what the kids are doing, but
you've seen like red baseball cards and
stuff like that with different
superimposed picture layers that become
visible as you move.
That's not the sense of Hologram that's
at stake.
Although maybe so we'll get to why, but
we'll focus on the Hologram theoretic
formulation.
So, to summarize, in the Holographic
principle version of the Free Energy
Principle, the quantum information
theoretic version of the principle, all
of the classical information that I need
as an external observer to characterize
the coupling between two subsystems of a
larger system exist on the boundary.
And that's a pretty remarkable physical
fact.
And a few years ago, Chris Fields, Jim
Glazebrook and Mike Levin proposed that
maybe this kind of information
concentrating bottleneck architecture
also has application to consciousness in
the form of an internal screen.
So the idea was that the information that
I bring to bear, to parse my sensory
stream and make sense of what is
constantly bombarding me, it has to live
somewhere.
And so the idea is, well, it lives in
this inner screen.
So you basically have an external Markov
blanket, which is a Markov blanket just
in the usual sense.
And then the idea is well within the set
of internal states that are kind of
partitioned off from the organisms due to
the organism's Markov blanket.
Then you would have an internal Markov
blanket structure within those internal
states.
This is prediction six from their great
paper.
Minimal physicalism internal awareness
requires internal boundaries.
And there's this interesting connection
to integrated information theory I am
agnostic with respect to IIT, so we're
not going to go there today.
But for those of you who are interested,
this kind of inner loop mechanism seems
to generate positive integrated
information.
So there's an interesting connection
there.
Before I move on to Neurophysiology, I'll
hand things over to Mao.
If you wanted to add anything.
Mahault: Yeah, actually I was literally
about to type something that this is
actually also connected to some
neomaterialist formulations of folding
onto itself.
So maybe this is something worth digging
into a little later in the talk.
Maxwell: Awesome.
Then we shall.
And I believe that Ali is also a co
author on the paper and we have him.
So congratulations, by the way, on the
preprint.
I saw it released and Mao has told me
about it.
I'm really happy to see such serious
philosophical work being done with the
Free Energy Principle as the basis.
I think you should be very happy with the
end result and proud.
But now let me get back to my monologue.
So rather our Mao and my diet.
It's not really a dialogue.
It's sort of like I don't know how to
call it.
Anyway, I'm thinking in French.
I have the words in French, I promise.
So now that we've, you know, reviewed in
a very much too short, way too brutally
fast fashion the Free Energy Principle
and its core formulations, we're now
going to derive a model of consciousness
by applying it to the known
neurophysiology of the brain.
Are you ready?
You buckled up?
Okay, good.
So we have just said that the FEP can be
used to model things that have boundaries.
.
I submit to you that the brain is a thing
with boundaries and importantly, a lot,
many, several internal boundaries.
So in particular, we know that the brain
has a very sparse structure.
So if you think of just the raw numbers,
right?
There are roughly on the order of 100 and
5160 billion neurons in the brain.
But each neuron only makes about
something like, I want to say five
figures, because I've spent so long, ten
to the five connections, right?
My neurophysiology is a bit far behind me,
, but it's something on the order of a
few thousand to maybe tens of thousands
of connections per neuron.
So obviously, if you just think about it,
most neurons are not connected to each
other, not directly.
And furthermore, the brain has a
hierarchical structure.
And when you think about it, what is a
hierarchy?
A hierarchy is a sparse connectivity
structure, right?
So if you think about a hierarchy of
connectivity, what having a hierarchical
structure means, at the end of the day,
this isn't some statement about power
dynamics where things at the top of the
hierarchy are more important than things
at the bottom.
Your cortical neurons don't drain more
juice than other parts of the brain.
The neurons in those parts.
What we're talking about is a regular
sparse pattern of connectivity, where I
only make connections to the layers
directly below me and to the layers
directly above me.
What I want to suggest now is that you
can understand the sparseness as a set of
nested Markov blankets, and that's going
to do a lot of heavy lifting for us.
So the discussions here are based on two
papers.
One by Fields and colleagues called
neurons as hierarchies of quantum
reference frames.
It's really cool.
I recommend it.
And also a paper by Inesh Ipolito, myself
and our colleagues on Markov blankets in
the brain.
So this is going to be a much too short
summary of those discussions, but
basically, you can start with individual
neurons and then talk about their Markov
blankets to bring it back to something
that I was saying earlier, but that I
didn't emphasize while we were going
through the slides.
The Markov blanket identifies dynamical
dependencies, not necessarily physical
boundaries.
So it's a statistical boundary it's not
necessarily like the boundaries of a wall,
, like a cell.
In the case of formalizing individual
neurons with Markov blanket we would
associate the post synaptic conductance
with the internal states, the post
synaptic voltage with the active states,
the presynaptic conductance to external
states and the presynaptic voltage to
sensory states.
You have some equations of motion that
tell you how each of these quantities
change and what they depend on.
And you'll notice that this has the
dependency structure of a Markov blanket
where the internal states only depend on
sensory active and internal states, the
active states only depend on internal
states, and so on.
So it respects the dependency structures
that we were discussing a bit earlier,
where again, the sensory states can only
depend on other blanket states and
external states and so on.
So here we have a nice dynamic Markov
blanket that we carve around our neurons.
.
And then there are two directions that we
can go.
We can ascend the scales towards
canonical microcircuits and then cortical
columns, individual brain regions, whole
brain networks and so on.
And at each of these successive scales of
self organization you can similarly
identify Markov blanket.
If you want to discuss this in more
detail, you can go see the paper by Inesh
and myself and colleagues.
You can also go from the individual
neuron down towards gated channels,
towards synapses dendrites and the soma.
So the body of the cell, all of these
things have successive Markov blanket.
And so all throughout the brain's
organization at the different scales at
which itself organizes.
You have this nice structure of nested
Markov blankets, of Markov blankets?
Of Markov blankets.
So that's one clear immediate sense in
which there are these blankets.
And you can start to think of these
blankets as screens in the way that we
just were talking about.
A slightly more illustrative example of
what we're talking about here is Markov
blankets and predictive coding.
This is a figure pretty typical in the
predictive coding literature.
What it tells you is that the brain has a
series of levels or layers, where
superordinate layers are basically
passing predictions about sensory input
onto subordinate layers and subordinate
layers are shuffling prediction error
back up to the superordinate layers.
This is probably like I'm almost
embarrassed again to discuss this at the
active inference institute.
I'm sure everyone is quite familiar with
these things already.
The novelty that we are introducing here
is to say well, each of these layers is
connected to each other via a Markov
blanket.
And so that's I think like a key insight
is that each of these layers has internal
states and communicates to other layers
through what you can formalize as a
Markov blanket.
So you can understand at any given scale
of brain activity, you can understand the
different levels of message passing as
successively nested screens.
The cool thing is that what each of these
screens is doing in some sense is course
graining, the stuff in the screen below.
So in some sense each screen is kind of
implicitly contained in the following one.
.
And what you end up having is a kind of
nested structure of screens of screens of
screens of screens, which is, I think,
pretty cool.
We recover, as you'll note in this figure,
, the inner screen hypothesis.
Each of these, this is probably a better
way to visualize it.
You have at the left the kind of external
Markov blanket of the organism.
It is segregating or carving out a set of
internal states.
And what we're saying is these internal
states have a layered level structure, a
sparse structure that we can formalize
using nested Markov blanket.
And like I was saying, each screen
successively coarse grains the next
screen.
And this gives some flesh to this notion
of contextual computing, this idea that
really what the brain is, is an organ of
context where each layer is providing
context to the layer below and where each
layer is attuning to increasingly higher
order, slower and more physically
widespread regularities.
So one thing that we're proposing here,
which is a novel hypothesis that we
intend to test empirically over the next
few years, is that this architecture has
two special layers.
In some sense you can think about it as
write only layers.
So if you're thinking about the stack,
the sensory periphery or the sensory
bottom, in one sense can only write in
one direction, it can only write into the
system and the topmost level can only
write downwards.
This is a key architectural feature.
One thing to point out is that in the
paper we associated the topmost level to
structures like the hippocampus.
We don't need to suggest that the
hippocampus is uniquely the top of this
hierarchy.
Rather there is probably a whole bulk of
structures that basically cannot any
longer be coarse grained.
So you kind of have like an executive
level top.
And what's particular about this top is
that it can only write down into the
stack.
So its function really is to be about and
monitor the other layers of the stack,
implementing a form of covert action
which trickles down throughout the stack.
.
So, Mahault, I saw you write some stuff.
Would you like to add?
Mahault: Yeah, so I think one of the
things that's important to highlight is
why some things can only write up and
some things can only write down.
And what this means for irreducible, the
irreducible mark of blanket, which is the
part where experience happens because
there's a counter that and some future
questions that are going to happen that
relates to superstructures and then why
don't we experience the consciousness of
a superstructure?
So I think it might be important to dig
into that a little bit.
Maxwell: Absolutely.
Thank you.
So, yeah, to summarize then, there are
basically two, right, only layers.
As you ascend the layers which are
successively coarse graining each other,
there is an irreducible screen that can't
further be coarse grained.
We believe that this corresponds to
something like a naturalized Homunculus.
And we're calling this perspective (with
an intentional provocation) -
"we're calling this perspective ""
"Neocartesian,"" in the sense that we may
have in some sense identified the
processes that make it seem as if there
was something like a Homunculus."
Obviously we're not - or maybe not
obviously! It's worth saying we are not
falling into the Homunculus fallacy
because we're not claiming that the
topmost layers perceive themselves.
So the buck stops with the top layers and
the top layers can only perceive
themselves vicariously by acting through
other layers.
And we associate this action of layers of
internal Markov blankets on each other
with attention in particular and other
neuromodulatory effects.
So I mean the overall picture is one
where consciousness is intrinsically
related to overt and covert actions, to
the overt acting and sensing associated
with the external Markov blanket and with
the covert actions that are being
deployed within the stack and in
particular that are issued by the very
top set of levels.
As I said, this is not necessarily a
strict hierarchy.
It could be a hierarchy with several
different tops.
But this integrated top structure we
believe could be associated with a
naturalized Homunculus.
I'm going to skip through the rest and
thank you for your attention.
Unless Mahault wants to add something.
Mahault: Just one thing is, I think to
put it in simpler terms as well, the two
layers that can only write can't store
memories.
Because that's right, memories is not
just an encoding, it's a process of
retrieval.
And it requires interactions between
different levels, which is why the lowest
levels are only interacting with things
which are external and therefore can't
necessarily store and can't make direct
interactions with anything else within
the entity itself, and the highest level
as well.
So there is no memories being encoded at
these two levels, which is why they're
right only and not.
I think that helps a little bit.
Maxwell: Thank you.
Yeah, I would agree.
So thank you all for your attention.
Thank you in particular, Dan, for the
invitation.
It's always great to be at the A-Double-
-I! And yeah, we [were] looking forward
to this discussion.
Mahault: I think Daniel said he wasn't
going to do too much animation, so if
people have
Maxwell: Are you going to do any
facilitation at all, Dan?
Mahault: Yeah.
MARIA LUIZA IENNACO: Okay.
Maria: So thanks Maxwell and Mahault for
the amazing talk!
There are so many interesting things to
dig on in this paper, I don't know even
where to start.
But I do have one question too, actually,
in particular.
So: Does this inner screen model imply a
kind of proto-panpsychism or a more
restricted bio-psychism?
I mean, do you think the type of nested
Holographic structure described by the
model all exists in biological systems?
And regardless of the answer, would you
think that it generalizes to larger
systems comprising these systems, like
populations and colonies and so on?
Maxwell: Maybe I can take
a quick stab at that.
So we think that the Free Energy
Principle itself commits you to a kind of
I don't know what the right word is.
We're writing a paper now.
We're struggling with the exact coinage,
but it's not quite a pen psychism.
It's a pen representationalism or a pen
tracking ism, if you'll allow me, the
absolutely disgusting neologism.
Basically what the FEP implies is that
anything that has a boundary, it looks as
if it's tracking what's beyond the
boundary.
So at a very basic level, the FEP kind of
licenses this talk about anything.
So anything whatsoever looks as if it's
tracking what's across the boundary by
virtue of existing.
So at a very basic level, if I see a rock
outside, I know that it's not 1000
degrees Celsius outside.
Right.
The fact that a rock has a specific
structure entails something about its
environment.
Likewise, I can see you, Maria, you are
not wearing a winter parka.
And I can infer from that that it's
probably room temperature around you and
not like you're not somewhere in
Antarctica or wherever else.
So this kind of basic tracking
relationship applies to everything.
What we've tried to do in this paper is
to start spelling out more explicitly
what the difference is between just rocks
and rock stars in some sense.
Like, what is the special kind of
structure that you need to add to the
Markov blanket?
And what you'll notice is that you get
consciousness by making the overall
structure more sparse.
So as you make more of the connectivity
zero, you get all of these weird things
that pop up, one of which is we think
like this consciousness structure.
Mao has thought about this maybe more
than I have, so I'd be curious to get her
perspective.
Mahault: Well, so I know that people are
a little bit wary of panpsychism, so we
usually add the term proto in front of it.
.
And so the idea is that we have to
deconceptualize what consciousness means.
.
And oftentimes what we mean is something
that resembles what humans do.
And we have to be a little bit if we take
our formalism consciousness can become
emergent at the scales where humans are.
But it doesn't mean that it doesn't exist
at lower scales, where the inertia or the
entropy generated by policies is lower.
So if you think of a rock, its policy is
pretty much maintained bonds.
You know what I mean?
There's nothing else.
The scale at which some kind of thing
exists and changes is much different than
you deciding to have coffee.
But in effect, your cells could be
something that we could consider exist,
closer to something that a rock does and
even lower just the proteins that make up
your system.
So if we understand that there is
nestedness and that the conscious process
happens once you have this capacity to
exchange information across layers,
anything that has the stacking of layers
in a nested fashion is in effect, proto
conscious.
But we have to be very careful about what
we load into.
The term conscious, I think, is mainly
the question.
Maxwell: I'm sharing my screen here.
This is from a paper on path integrals,
particular kinds and strange particles.
So it is a typology of different kinds of
Markov blankets and different kinds of
particles.
So something like a rock, it still has a
Markov blanket, but its Markov blanket is
not partitioned into sensory and active
states.
There are no states that have this
property that active states have that
they affect the external world that are
not affected by it.
In return.
A rock just has sensory states.
If I kick a rock, unless it's radioactive,
, it's not going to act on me.
It only has the inference part of active
inference.
It's only kind of changing its state as a
response to the forces that are acting on
it.
Active particles are particles that have
both sensory and active states.
And you might think, for example, of a
cell.
A cell has this kind of structure.
Particles like ourselves have additional
sparseness in the Markov blanket, in
particular, what we call strange
particles.
The internal states of strange particles
do not have direct access to the active
states of strange particles, and
therefore they need to be inferred.
And this is what gets you planning.
At the end of the day, a strange particle
can only exist by kind of inferring
itself into existence precisely because
there are no direct connections between
the active and the internal states.
So as you remove connectivity from the
overall structure from here to here, you'
're adding sparseness.
From here to here, you're adding
sparseness.
As you make the system more and more
sparse, you get more and more interesting
behavior to emerge from the system.
And you can think of the topmost
structure that we were describing as an
instance of this broader architecture
where the topmost layer doesn't have
direct access to the active states of the
system.
And therefore, it kind of has to go
through the entire bulk of the system to
infer itself into existence.
Mahault: So there's a few hands up there
on Google where you can see the people
who share hand.
Okay.
So, Ali, I think you raised your hand
first.
Ali: Yes.
Thank you again for your crystal clear
and really illuminating talk.
I've written down three questions, but
maybe I'll begin with probably the most
basic and naive one.
So in some of the earlier literature on
active inference and the FEP, there was
this emphasis on distinguishing between
generative process and generative model.
But in this paper, in figure one, which
you also shown in your slides, we don't
see any generative process in the diagram.
.
So where does generative process fit into
this diagram?
Because the way I see it, it's basically
somehow included in the generative model
or I don't know.
What is the distinction between these two
concepts?
Maxwell: So you'll have to forgive some
of the earlier literature for this, there'
's some terminological inconsistency.
The only two constructs that are at play
here are the generative model and the
variational density that's encoded by
internal states.
That's it.
So it is not the case that the FEP is
about how the generative models the
generative process.
A lot of this language comes from
previous Bayesian approaches and in
particular, the helmholtz machine.
In the helmholtz machine.
So helmholtz machines are some of the
earlier predictive coding machines.
And in the helmholtz machine, basically
you have a forward pass that connects the
sensory end to basically the top of the
predictive hierarchy and then a backwards
pass connecting top of the model back to
the sensory end.
And in a helmholtz machine, you would
call the forward pass a recognition model
and the backwards pass a generative model.
.
The forwards passes a recognition model
because you're inputting some data and
then basically by the time the
information trickles up to the top, you
have recognized what caused the data.
And the backwards pass is called a
generative model for the reasons that are
sometimes invoked in the predictive
coding literature where you're basically
generating possible sensoria given a
certain configuration of states.
So we don't use recognition and
generative in that sense anymore.
And I apologize.
In some previous publications, I've been
a bit sloppy in the way that I use my
language and I've used the term
recognition density.
What's really at stake is and I'll share
my screen just to help make the point.
It's what it says here.
So you have your generative model,
right?
Your generative model is a joint
probability density.
So what is a joint probability density?
Well, you have a bunch of different
basically states that your system is
defined over and you have a probability
density that the shape of which captures
the way that states can change over time.
.
So, like, if I change this way, then I
need to change in that way.
And that's what this shape encodes.
And what the FEP says is if my generative
model has a certain sparseness, if it has
Markov blanket, then there's this
additional probability density that I can
define.
It is parameterized by the internal
states of the system.
It's called the variational density.
And this is like my probabilistic best
guess about what's causing my external
states.
At no point do you need to appeal to any
other bits of generative process when you'
're actually coding these models up in
MATLAB or in Python.
What we call the generative process is
just the equations of motion that govern
external states.
So if you actually hand code one of these
one day, your generative process might
include like, Newtonian physics and
whatever else.
It's sort of just like what is the
process that actually animates the
dynamics of external states?
In some very simple models, like in the
ones used by Miguel Aguilera and
colleagues, you're looking at linear
dissipative systems and they don't have
any dynamics right.
So basically, the system kind of just
dissipates.
A linear dissipative system is a dampened
spring physically, right?
So it just goes spring and then it
dissipates to the fixed point.
So similarly, you may or may not have
dynamics to the external states and that'
's what gets harnessed in the generative
process.
This should be clear.
Yeah.
Sorry. Mahault.
Mahault: No, I mean, I think what the
question that Ali is asking also has some
important correlates that often get asked
to us, like what's the difference between
consciousness or dreaming?
Or what's the difference between a dead
system that decays or being psychotic?
And I think what Maxwell is saying is our
system currently doesn't say anything
about your actual connection to the real
world other than a thing, which is
successful at being a thing, is probably
well joined relative to its needs to the
world.
And therefore your relation to reality
has probably got a better grasp if you
are functional for a longer amount of
time, this minus senescence.
So yeah, does that kind of help also,
Ali?
Ali: Yes.
Thank you both.
It really makes a lot more sense now.
Thank you so much.
Maxwell: Well, it's my pleasure.
And remember, model just means joint
probability density here.
Right?
There's a criminally underappreciated
paper that Karl wrote in Entropy in 2012
called  A Free Energy Principle for
Biological Systems, which is where a lot
of the Markov blanket story comes from.
And in that paper, Karl refers to the
generative model as just the generative
density.
So it's basically saying there's an
underlying probability density;
it describes the way that the dynamics
are being generated just generally;
and then if that density has the
appropriate structure, meaning if it has
like, zeros in the right places, then you
can define this other tracking density
that approximates the generative model or
density.
Ali: And I also have a follow up question,
, which I'll ask after Samuel and Thale's
questions.
Samuel: Okay, thanks for the excellent
talk.
I'm a professor at the State University
of Minas Gerais.
I'm a philosopher, cognitive scientist,
psychologist.
So I work mainly on reasoning.
But by reading your paper, what strikes
me as most promising is the possibility
of solving the hard problem of
consciousness, if this goes right in
progressing this model.
But maybe an important part of that
depends on exactly what is meant by
holograms, and exactly what this brings
into a theory as an explanation,
right?
So during your presentation, you were
talking something about that there's a
difference between holography in the
sense of bringing light to something to
make a projection; but you said that
might be related as well.
So I'm quite curious about how to use
this concept and how to understand it in
a more folk-psychology sense; and also
like where it comes from, because I'm not
a physicist.
So does it depend on string theory to be
correct?
Could you dive in a little more on this
concept first?
Maxwell: Mahault, I think this is more a
you question.
Mahault: So for the holographic screen
theory.
So basically, remember, Maxwell really
gave a good explanation.
I kind of thought I had answered your
question, but I'm going to give a little
bit.
So the boundary between any two mutually
separation systems, a and B, is the
holographic screen that encodes the
eigenvalues of the interaction that
couples A and B.
So this is very similar to how a hologram
encodes information about 3D objects onto
a 2D surface.
So A hologram stores information about
the phase and the amplitude of light
reflected from an object, and this allows
the reconstruction of a 3D image from a
2D surface.
And so here, similarly, the holographic
screen encodes information about a system'
's interaction with its environment,
which allows for the prediction and
control of the system's behavior.
Samuel: Yeah, but does it maybe allow for
the creation of an image?
That's the sort of question.
Mahault: Yeah, this is where we're giving
it some thought, actually.
So the creation of an image is a complex
idea because what's an image, right?
But effectively, there is some work being
done into information geometry and how
that may potentially interact with matter
in order to transmit information,
basically.
And so it's possible that the
reconstruction of information is done
through fields being changed such that
the modalities you have through your
senses, such as sight, hearing, touch,
are relative to the way that the
information needs to be transmitted in
terms of amplitude and velocity, et
cetera, which, in effect, gives you
something like light.
But that research is still relatively
early.
So, yes, it is promising.
It is leading in that direction.
It's probably one of the most interesting
formalism because it touches on the
connection between dynamics, matter, and
how information allows for matter to be
organized.
But all those pieces haven't properly
been put together.
It is heading there, though.
Maxwell: I would just add: So the
original monstrosity of a paper had a
section on explaining where qualia come
from based on the statistical patterns of
the input.
But as Mahault said, it was very early
work.
And, I mean, the core model was more or
less developed.
So we decided to spin that out as a
separate thing and then develop the inner
screen model of consciousness per se, to
flesh out a little bit or to add some
flesh to what Mahault was saying, which
is already pretty meaty as it is.
Have you heard of these experiments where
they take a little pad with little pins
on it and they basically reconstruct?
Well, they plug a camera on your head and
they put this little pad on your tongue,
and they blindfold you, and they
basically have you navigate.
And the camera generates a kind of
grayscale version of the image, but with
the little pins in terms of how far they
push in.
Samuel, are you seeing the image that I'm
discussing?
Samuel: No.
Maxwell: You have a little pad.
It has little pins that can push at
various depths.
And what you can do is basically
translate the image from the camera into
a different array of, like, assorted pins.
.
And so, yeah, you put this on your tongue,
, and if you blindfold yourself and use
this camera for about 20 to 30 minutes,
the brain eventually recognizes that, oh,
this is supposed to go to the visual area.
.
And then you start to see through your
tongue.
In some weird way, the body actually
recognizes the statistical frequencies of
the pins actually pushing onto your
tongue.
This is experienced not as, like, a
physical sensation, but actually visually
like you start to experience an
impoverished, grayscale visual field just
from the sensations that are being fed to
your tongue, which suggests that there's
something deeply deep about the
statistical structures of the signals
that are being processed and the way that
the qualia show up in your experience.
But this is still, like, super far off,
and I wouldn't have the pretension to
claim that we've cracked where qualia
come from just yet.
Samuel: Yeah, I get what you're saying
now.
Different patterns can make different
quality.
You don't need different magic to have
different quality.
But yeah, I was wondering how that
related to the holograms, but okay.
It's something in development, as you're
saying.
Maybe I should let someone go and then I'
'll go back to these consciousness
questions.
Mahault: Sure.
So, Thales.
Thales: Well, thank you all.
It was a great presentation and great
test, by the way.
IMAX.
Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
I'm sorry, you guys are facing like a
black screen right now.
My camera is off.
Sorry.
Okay.
I'm an anthropologist psychologist, so I'
'm kind of an outsider in here.
I'm not from the Active Inference Lab too.
. So I study it, but I'm not a specialist
in it.
So my questions are kind of broad and
they're actually really simple.
But I think that I'm only allowed to make
one question right per row.
Actually, my first question will be
something that Maria was talking about
before this meeting started.
So in the article account, consciousness
is an attribute of things that possesses
an reducible marker blanket, right.
With active states, exerting influence
and over external dynamics.
So when applying to the
neurophysiological space of the human
brain, talking about neuromodulatory
influence over neuronal dynamics.
And with that in mind, I would like to
know, could you speculate a little bit on
the implications of this characterization
of consciousness for how it might emerge
during infant or field development.
Maxwell: That's a great set of questions.
.
I gave a version of this talk to Luis
Pasoa's group at the Neuroscience and
Philosophy Salon, and Anna Shaunika asked
a similar question.
Mahault probably has a better response.
I would point you in the direction of the
work of Anna Shaunika.
She has some really cool work on co
embodiment and cohomeostasis and
pregnancy and this kind of thing.
I confess that I need to think about the
way that presumably you could just
continue extending this outwards.
Right.
So we've talked about inner screens and
there's like an external screen, but
presumably you could just reapply this
whole screen talk in the other direction
on the other side of yeah, exactly.
The first prior.
Well, the first prior is one of those
papers, but she's got like another set of
papers.
Yeah, this might be it.
Right.
Mahault: One thing to also consider is
the sparseness aspect of our model.
So as you develop, you prune connections
and you become more and more sparse,
which gives you more path approximations
to the way that information gets
agglomerated to form patterns that are
recognizable.
And so perhaps this has something to do
with the emergence of a moment where you
sort of come online because there's
something like an irreducible mark of
blanket that emerges by virtue of having
pruned enough such that you can now make
sense of the stimuli relative to some
couplings in time.
Rather than just hungry, there might be
something to that effect.
However, we need to be careful again,
with infants.
What we mean about consciousness, like,
do you mean selfhood?
Do you mean the capacity to reflect on
selfhood, or do you mean the capacity to
learn and act on the world, which is
closer to where we're headed?
Because while babies may not necessarily
have this capacity to reflect on their
selfhood right away, they do have the
capacity to react to signals and act on
the signals in order to get to a point
where their preferred states are enacted.
.
So baby is hungry, cries, food comes.
So there is a degree to which a baby,
much like a cell, has a degree of
consciousness relative to our model.
Maxwell: So I'd also point you in the
direction of Roslyn Moran's work on the
aging brain.
She's got some cool work that suggests
that the precision of our model increases
over time, which has to do a little bit
with what Miles discussing earlier.
We know just from neuroanatomy that the
process of pruning brain connections only
accelerates through time.
And basically that means that you're
disconnecting certain things from certain
others.
Right?
Like expertise has more to do with
understanding what is not connected to
what than understanding what is connected
to what.
And so, yeah, there is probably a kind of
developmental course whereby the model
becomes sparser and sparser and sparser
and sparser and more and more precise.
But this is a very cool direction for
exploration.
I don't know if I have anything more
cogent to say at this time about it.
Pleasure.
Mahault: So I know Ali wanted a second go,
, and so did Samuel.
Does anybody else have other questions?
Because no other hands are raised at this
time.
So we have one more hand, I
think.
Ali: Actually, you basically answered my
other questions, so thank you so much.
Mahault: Awesome.
So then Thales has his hand up again.
Maria says her hand up, and Samuel has
hand up.
So Thales first,
I suppose.
Thales: I don't know guys like to Maria
first, because I just know.
Mahault: Sure, go ahead, Maria.
All right.
Maria: I didn't say before, but I am a
psychologist and master in philosophy,
and now I'm doing PhD in philosophy as
well.
And it's not really a question.
I would just like to understand better
what is memory in your inner mother,
because I understand the information
passing and the middle layers or levels
that contain the information.
But how exactly do we construct, for
example, the narrative self or something
that we remember from a long time, or
episodic memory?
I didn't understand it very well in the
paper.
So if you could just shed some.
Maxwell: It's a computer science
processing, information processing notion
of memory.
So you get some data and you need to
parse it into things that are causing
that data.
Well, presumably you need to leverage
some beliefs or knowledge about how to
parse that data.
And that comes in the form of information.
.
Basically, you need to have some capacity
to reduce the entropy of your
observations and to kind of carve things
out into things.
And the inner screen serves as the locus
where the information is encoded.
So that's the cool thing about the
quantum version of the Markov blanket
formulation.
It tells you where all of the information
that characterizes the coupling across
two bulks where it lives, basically.
I mean, to get a little bit more
technical, the Markov blanket itself is
constituted by the degrees of freedom
that couple the two systems together.
And, yeah, you can think of this as an
array of bits that answer yes no
questions about are the two systems
communicating across this channel yes or
no?
And in some sense, the state of the
blanket at any given time gives you all
of the information that you need to
characterize the coupling in terms of
these yes no questions.
So all of the classical information that
you need to characterize the coupling
lives on the blanket.
And, yes, having an internal blanket
means that you can have an internal store
of such answers to yes no questions that
you can then use to parse the sensory
stream.
But in a kind of standard computer
architecture, it's just saying that you
have a memory register, right?
Yeah.
You need to store some of the information
that you're processing somewhere so that
you can deploy it.
And the idea is that it lives on this
internal screen.
Does that help?
Maria: And in this case, it would be the
hippocampus.
Maxwell: Yeah, all of the inner screens
encode information in this sense.
Right.
The point of having inner screen
structure at all is to kind of retain
information to parse your sensory stream.
.
And yeah, structures like the hippocampus,
, like these upper brain stem structures,
what used to be called the limbic brain
and so on, we think that these are all at
the top.
The idea, right, is that so you have your
sensory motor end, then you have your
prefrontal cortex, which is the
controller for the sensory motor end.
It's a controller in the sense that its
main function is to inhibit activity in
the sensory motor area.
But if the main function of prefrontal
cortex is to go to the rest of the brain,
then there is also a part of the brain
whose main function it is to go to the
prefrontal cortex, and that is these are
these upper regions that we're describing.
.
So, yes, the memory registers live in
this whole stack.
Ultimately, the point about memory is
less unique to this apex structure.
What is unique to these top structures,
though, is the right only kind of
directionality that they don't have any
context,
Right?
There is no higher structure that can
provide memory to these top layers.
So all they can do is act,
Right?
In particular, they act in a kind of
covert fashion on other layers of the
brain, I think would be the answer to
that.
Mahault, did you want to add anything to
that?
Mahault: You touched on the notion of
selfhood and how the narrative self
unfolds over time and leverages memory.
And our model basically established what
selfhood the process of selfing is
because according to our model and very
alike, very like Thomas Metzinger's model
of selfhood, it's a process, not a thing.
.
So selfing is the process by which the
internal states are capable of mapping to
the relevant external states such that
they can act in such a way as to fulfill
their own needs.
This is also very close to what Neil Seth
said about the Beast machine.
And so if you have nested structure and
each of these nested structure has a
timescale say so you have structures that
happen on the milliseconds and some
timescales that happen on the scale of a
sentence and then some structures that
track much longer timescales like your
life goal and in your ancestry and stuff
like that.
You find that memory is just the storing
the binning of the relevant information
at the timescale at which it is relevant.
.
And so you can retrieve the relevant
information for the shorter timescales
because it acts as a prior for the lower
timescale.
Does that help for the narrative?
Maria: So yes.
Thank you.
Mahault: Awesome.
Sure, go ahead, Samuel.
Samuel: Yeah, about the going back to the
Band psychiatrist problem and how you
describe consciousness, I think it's very
well, it's old in the literature that you
can have information processing which is
not conscious, but it's mental in some
sense in other animals or the beings
which are not biological beings.
But when you describe your models, I know
you have this level also but you also
have a level of phenomenal awareness or
phenomenal consciousness which you are
describing.
And I think that's the most particularly
important part of the model, the
phenomenal awareness part.
And it's the part of the model that can
contribute to something new to me in a
sense that wasn't described.
So I'm glad you mentioned Matzinger
because Matsinger is one of the few who
have described consciousness as a virtual
reality.
And what I think is interesting about
describing consciousness as a virtual
reality is that it makes a difference
between mental information processing or
unconscious information processing and
those processes that are conscious
because they are simulated somehow.
So an interesting thing of having a
different language to speak of conscious
events is that we can then explain why
they are different.
We can explain why we have images in our
head or something like that, and why
these images seem to have causal powers,
if they have at all.
So when I imagine something, I can make
my hand move or something like that and
you can describe this only with
electrical information or something like
that, but it doesn't explain why we have
different information processes with
consciousness and those without
consciousness.
And I know all theory of consciousness
have a distinction between the
unconscious and the conscious level.
But adding something like the metaphysics
of virtual reality would explain the
metaphysics of causation.
For instance, if you're playing a video
game.
Does the content of that game matter for
causation?
Or is it just the information that's
stored in the computer that matters?
There's a variable there which means a
sword.
Does it meaning a sword make any
difference at all?
And I think that's something that hasn't
been very much discussed in philosophy.
So David Chalmers has just written a book
recently about virtual reality, but it
doesn't apply to consciousness yet.
And I think if you guys find something in
physics that's different, as you guys are
trying to do, as you admitted having that
aim, then maybe there could be some sort
of different physical explanation to
conscious causation.
So I would like you guys to comment on
that.
Maxwell: That's really interesting.
We draw on medsinger's work, on opacity
and transparency.
So in medsinger's work, just for the
audience, there are two kinds of
cognitive processes.
There are transparent processes that we
are not aware of as cognitive processes
per se, and then there are opaque
processes which we are.
So, for instance, the metaphor comes from
a transparent or opaque window.
And most of the time, the window just
lets you see through it towards whatever
is on the other side, but sometimes it's
a bit grimy, and then you see the window
itself.
And so, similarly, there are some
processes that mainly deliver things in
the world, and then there are other
processes that deliver mental processes
to us as kind of the object of our
perception in some sense.
So these are processes like attention or
attentional processing, or paying
attention to your own attentional state.
These processes make other processes
opaque.
"Terrence Deacon, the anthropologist,
also talks about similar phenomena in
terms of, like, absent absence and what
he calls ""absential phenomena."""
So there's a sense in which this top
layer, what it does is implement
opacification.
So the top layer can only be about other
layers in the stack.
And this kind of reversal of the flow of
information is, we think, the key to
understanding the way that mental
processes are made available for
introspection at all.
Yeah, so that's how I would respond.
Mahault, I saw you turn your camera on.
Do you have more to
Mahault: No, I don't have more to answer
that question.
Maxwell: Cool.
Mahault: So, Thales, do you have another
question?
Thales: Yeah, I know guys have already
discussed some of this before, especially
on Twitter, but if you can just repeat it,
, because if I understood it right when
applying the model to human neurobiology,
the article kind of seems to account
within central neurosystem.
Maxwell: Could you repeat the last
thing?
You broke up pretty bad on my.
Thales: Sorry, my laptop is really okay.
The article seems to align itself to a
more modular account of the central
nervous system.
But in contrast to modeler accounts,
there are some dynamic distributor
approaches that suggest that there are no
parts of the brain with dedicated
functions, right?
But regions with various capacities
present in software assembled test
specific coalitions.
So these coalitions sometimes are termed
like transiently assembled local neuronal
subsystems, right?
Maxwell: Yeah, we're big fans of big fans.
.
Thales: Yeah, exactly.
So these approaches specialism is only a
functional footprint and brain functions
never the result of fixed networks
implementing specific processes, but the
result of high order relations between
regions.
So my question with that in mind, knowing
that you guys know these kind of
approaches, right?
Do I think that the level erco structure
implied by the model could be cash out in
terms of transient collisions built on
the flight, such as flow talents?
Maxwell: Yes.
I mean, we have a paper doing that from
2020.
It's called neural and phenotypic
representations under the Free Energy
Principle.
And it is one of our lesser known papers.
.
Let me just put it in the chat quickly.
And so what we show in this paper is that
it's possible to simulate the transient
formation of Markov blankets that
basically track stimulus features.
So there are a lot of moving parts to
what you were saying.
On the one hand, yes, you can totally use
the Markov blanket formalism to model the
transient formation and assembly of these.
.
I would also add that there's a new
perspective on modularity that opens up
via the Free Energy Principle.
It's best explored in this paper by
Thomas Parr Inesh Ipolito and a few
others called modules or mean fields,
where the argument and again, this
dovetails nicely with what Mike Anderson
and his group are doing currently.
The argument is that the specialization
of brain regions is not functional, it's
computational.
And this is effectively what Mike
Anderson and company are arguing is that
each patch of the brain is specialized in
converting certain patterns into other
patterns.
It's not like you have a visual region or
I think Mike's example is the Broca's
area, which is associated with the
production of language is actually
activated in more non linguistic tasks
than in linguistic tasks.
So what that suggests is that each brain
area is kind of like contributing certain
stereotyped forms of computation to the
overall process that's unfolding in the
brain.
And in the Free Energy Principle
literature, you can understand that as a
kind of factorization.
Right?
So what and where we have two different
streams in the brain, the dorsal and the
ventral, which handle what I am seeing
and where I am seeing.
And basically the idea is that this
anatomical segregation of pathways
corresponds to a factorization and
inference.
Where you are and what you are are
independent.
You could be here.
I think I've tried to yeah.
Mahault: So that was a really good answer.
.
I'm going to try and say it a little bit
differently and see what sticks to the
wall.
So each hierarchical level of the brain
has markup blankets, right?
So remember, these things are nested and
they exchange with other levels according
to the dependency structures of the mark
of blankets.
And so this is like hierarchical
predictive coding, right?
So ascending prediction errors can be
read as active states, while descending
can constitute sensory states from the
point of view of a given level.
So using this factorization that Maxwell
just mentioned, some brain regions become
specialized to encode distinct
probability factors that are
statistically independent.
And this creates a sort of physiological
separation of brain regions, which imply
that the information encoded in these
regions is conditionally independent of
that encoded in other distinct regions.
So it allows for the formation of new
functions as the brain regions interact.
So we get to the point of mental action.
This is enabled by the existence of a
subsystem that is both irreducible, so
there exists no further mark of blanket
partitions of the internal states and
complex or expressive enough to act like
a suitably flexible meta controller.
So this metacontroller coordinates overt
and covert action.
That's the last part of what Maxwell
explained, which could be seen as forming
transient connections.
Right?
So that's the point of precision
weighting.
So the nested scales of increasingly
large ensembles of neurons basically form
coherently, and so they also have their
own Markov blankets.
So we can generalize different nested
connectivity structures in the brain,
where we find formally identical patterns
at subordinate levels and superordinate
scales.
So does that help restructure what
Maxwell said?
Basically.
Thales: Yes, it did.
Mahault: Awesome.
So Samuel still has his hand up.
I think Ali also has his hand up.
Ali didn't go yet.
Samuel, do you mind if Ali goes first?
Samuel: Sure, go ahead.
Ali: Thank you.
Yeah, I just wanted to make a couple of
comments about the notion of self
evidencing or self modeling that's just
been discussed.
Because, you see, sometimes in
philosophical literature, the sensibility
of secondary properties are usually they'
're divided into the sensibility of
things in itself and sensibility of
things for itself.
But under these conditions, some
philosophers believe that real sensation
would not be possible.
Or as Arthur Rimbo famously put it, I is
an other.
Right.
But in some recent developments,
particularly in process materialism,
through the work of people like Thomas
Neal, Emmanuel Delanden, Karen Broad,
they've tried to somehow overcome this
issue, this philosophical distinction
between in itself and for itself, by
introducing the notion of self
receptivity, or, in other words, a
capacity to be affected and to affect at
the same time.
Because by introducing self receptivity,
then the sensation of each sensed point
in the flow can become itself as an other
to itself.
So basically, that distinction between in
itself and for itself would be dismantled
effectively.
And that's why it can provide more
reliable way to discuss the notion of
real sensation, or real even subjectivity,
, as a flow that just folds on itself and
comprises both in itself and by itself.
And that's also why I believe FEP and
active inference can provide, even on the
more philosophical note, more reliable
way to talk about what it means to sense
and be sensed at the same time.
Maxwell: I find that very compelling.
I know you and Mahault have been working
together, so I think Mahault might have
something more insightful than I think.
That's great, though.
Mahault: I agree.
I think I like linking these ideas to we
wrote in the consciousness text by
basically saying that your screen is the
folding onto itself.
Right.
It's going to be seen as the wrapping
inside another form the consciousness is
riped into the form, is wrapped in the
form of the mind.
And so if you partition internal and
external states, and the marker blankets
has these different kind of active and
sensory states, you can see how the
folding basically happens through this
loop that isn't necessarily happening,
because it's not only happening at one
scale, does not have to be non
simultaneous.
We consider that these things are
separated in time simply because we're
thinking of one timescale.
But so if we add this notion of
interaction, we can highlight the dynamic
and relational nature of consciousness to
refer to the process where the agent and
its environment actively shape one
another.
So the mind creating an inner screen here
just reflects its understanding of the
world and of itself through like,
basically of the world through its own
filter.
And the filter is a reflection of itself.
.
It's just that, effectively, if there are
errors, you need to be able to model what
parts of your filter created potentially
the error.
So, yeah, does that help kind of flesh
out this idea of folding onto itself and
incoming sensory data?
I think this question was for Ali or
Maxwell, so one of you has.
Maxwell: To decide whether I thought it
was for Ally.
Ali: That was great.
Mahault: Okay, cool.
Ali: Yeah, that was great.
Thanks.
Mahault: Awesome.
So, Samuel, I think you have a question.
Samuel: Yes, my final question, I was
mostly talking about the hard problem, of
course, because I also buy the predictive
processing story, and I agree with what
you guys are saying.
But one issue that I have with the
predictive processing story is that.
Maxwell: We.
Samuel: Can apply it to explanations in
various ways.
So sometimes, like, sometimes you can it
seems we can tell any story with the same
theory, and it's hard to know which one
is true if you can tell multiple stories.
.
So I think that's a problem with
predictive processing in general.
And you can explain, for instance, autism
in different ways, and I think people
have tried that for your model
unconsciousness.
How can we know that any of that is
true?
How empirical is it?
And during the talk, you guys mentioned
something that you were going to test
something based on this, which was very
promising, and I would like you to
comment on that.
Mahault: So Maxwell, he has a really cool
paper on the map territory fallacy policy,
, which I think is part of the answer
here.
And we've also written some.
So I'll let Maxwell dig into it.
Probably was.
Going to be a very fleshed out answer.
So I'll give a very small answer which he'
's going to blow out of the water
afterwards.
Maria: But.
Mahault: There are some things we can do
to test whether the predictions made by
our model actually come to fruition.
So that's one way to test the empirical
validity of a model.
But to keep in mind a model is just a
model.
And so since you have multiple
realizability effectively, what really
only matters is whether your model
actually has any predictive power.
So here let's say that we can examine
whether the brain structure and function
reflect the nested and hierarchical
organization which is predicted by our
model or whether interventions that alter
the brain structure or function lead to
changes in conscious experience as we
predicted.
Or for instance, we can test which parts
of the brain relate to which scale of
elements that are perceived and then make
predictions about the contents of
consciousness and their neural correlates
to see how well it maps.
So these are things that we could
empirically test.
Maxwell: I'll just add a bit of meta
flavor to that.
So remember, I started with the
distinction between dynamics, mechanics
and principles.
Personally, I don't like the verbiage of
predictive processing.
Frankly, I don't think it the term refers
to anything specific when people use the
term rigorously.
So Andy Clark introduced the term in his
2013 paper Whatever Next because he
wanted to talk about some broad kind of
approach, prediction involving approach
to explaining cognition.
But at the time he didn't want to commit
to any specific implementation of the
idea.
So he was like, here's predictive coding,
here's hierarchical predictive coding.
But as I'm sure you know, predictive
coding makes very specific predictions
about the neuronal implementation of the
theory.
So in particular, predictive coding
assumes that there are distinct neuronal
subpopulations that encode the error and
the prediction error.
He didn't necessarily want to commit to
one version of that because who knows,
maybe it's the same sub populations that
issue predictions and prediction errors
at different times and you have some kind
of time based rate coding or whatever
going on.
He also at the time didn't want to commit
to the Free Energy Principle per se.
But predictive processing doesn't really
denote a specific theory.
And one of the problems that emerged is
there's a whole bunch of literature
presenting accounts that are consistent
with predictive processing, which doesn't
mean anything really.
It just means, hey, you can kind of wave
your hands around and this kind of looks
like a prediction if you kind of look at
it the right way.
I think the more rigorous way to
understand this is to bring it back to
the math and say that there are
principles, mechanics and dynamics.
So there's some phenomenon that we want
to explain.
We have a formal description of it.
This might be like a data set or whatever
else describing the actual values of
whatever system you're considering.
The Free Energy Principle is deployed to
construct specific generative models
which provide you with the equations of
motion that explain that behavior.
Right?
So the generative model is, in effect, a
set of linked equations of motions that
you see here with these dependence
relationships.
So when you actually commit to a specific
generative model, then you are in a
terrain where you can bring empirical
evidence to kind of decide, validate or
to falsify the model.
So I would draw your attention to the
Free Energy Principle.
We know the Free Energy Principle is true
for mathematical reasons.
It would be as silly to try to invalidate
the FEP empirically as it would be to try
to falsify calculus by trying to observe
some phenomenon in the empirical world.
It is true mathematically.
And then you use that principle to derive
specific models which are then testable.
So I don't know if we've gone all the way
here.
So this is somewhere still kind of in
between an in principle explanation and a
specific model.
To get to more fleshed out empirical
predictions of the sort that now was
discussing, we would have to get a bit
more specific, which we're doing kind of
in parallel.
I don't feel ready to discuss the exact
predictions and the ways that we'll be
discussing them or exploring them,
testing them.
This is very much work in progress.
I can tell you it'll involve psychedelics,
, but that's pretty much where I'm not
comfortable extending any more than that.
.
I feel like I might expose a flank that's
not ready to be exposed.
Samuel: Perfect.
Thanks for that pleasure.
Maxwell: And that brings us to the end.
Thales, you have your hand up again.
Do you want to hop on?
Thales: Do we have time?
Maxwell: Yeah, I think we have time for
one more question.
Thales: Daniel, do you want to ask
something?
Because I really asked two times.
Okay.
Actually, I would like if you guys could
delve a little bit deeper in the
implications of Maria's first question.
It's the other side of the coin related
to the protopan psychics, the population
level conscious or conscious processes in
complex organisms sharing phenotype, for
example, like end colonies, or in a more
speculative sense, like complex organisms
aligned and shared, like a distributed
generative model in niche building
processes,
right?
So as Maxwell once said, the other side
of the natural selection process.
So given the sparsity and given the
transient conversions that these
populations are in this specific moment,
specific process, can we speculate
something about consciousness at this
level?
Thank you.
Mahault: All right.
I think Maxwell is staying quiet because
he expects me to sort of start answering
the question.
Maxwell: Correct.
Mahault: So we've done a lot of work in
simulating large scale systems, right?
So we've simulated niche, we've simulated
interaction between one, two, or more
actors, what it means for belief sharing,
propagation, the formation of mark of
blankets, et cetera.
And so I think the true question would be
how transient are the mark of blankets at
the level of superstructures and how does
it enable those structures to be able to
encode information at the level of the
interaction between different scales?
"So I do think that given our model you
can assume that a system is conscious by
virtue of having nested parts which can
read and write where a superordinate
entity level of the structure is ""write
only"" and the lower level is also ""
"write only."""
And through this sort of boundary of the
entity and the interactions between the
parts of the entity you have what
resembles a conscious process at which
you have some degree of perception.
The really interesting question there
becomes what becomes the irreducible
parts?
So if you could be understood a little
bit like a cell if you as a human, your
irreducibility is that your cell as a
part of a larger system,
what experiences at the system level?
And I think that's a really truly
interesting question.
If we look at ants, for instance, ants on
their own don't do much computation,
right?
But ants at a hive then become much more
interesting and they behave in a
coordinated fashion, which can look as if
they were making much more complex
computation.
And you could say the same for your cells.
.
Your cells in themselves, they have a
very simple process, very simple
computation.
But together, through these large scale
emerging coordinating patterns, some of
them become your skin, some of them
become your brain.
And the conscious part that you are
experiencing at the scale at which you
can understand consciousness currently,
that's where most information is lost
such that the irreducible part of your
consciousness is the parts that can
become opaque.
So I think I've answered most of your
question.
Maxwell: I would maybe just add that this
is not fully chartered territory and I
think there may be some agreements and
disagreements.
I'm always wary of the intentional
misattribution fallacy where we attribute
intentionality or mental properties to
things that don't end up having them.
I think that the kind of minimal
intentionality pan, intentionalism pan,
representationalism, whatever you want to
call it, that follows from the free
energy principle gets you a lot of the
intelligent looking behavior without
having to posit that there is actually
something it's like to be a city or
whatever.
What makes me skeptical of the idea that
there is such a thing is that what we are
suggesting is that what's necessary for
consciousness in the stronger kind of
agential sense is an external Markov
blanket that insulates a bunch of
internal states and then that these
internal states in turn have this kind of
nested structure.
And that's what I don't think there is in
say, like a city or like a higher order
kind of cultural I'd have to think about
this.
So you're kind of pushing at the limits
of where I'm comfortable thinking.
Which is appreciated, by the way.
Thank you for the challenging questions.
Yeah, but I think there's room for
disagreement and I might be wrong about
this.
I uh think we just have to keep pushing
to find out who's correct.
But I find what Mahault said interesting
and compelling and intriguing.
I am just intellectually conservative at
this point in my life, being an old man.
Mahault: This is why I think it's a
little bit complicated to fully answer
that question because we have
metaphorical tools but we don't have
anything ready yet to go any further.
One thing that I like to think about is
the only way you're ever going to
experience maybe what it's like to be
part of a consciousness which is entailed
by something more than you is having
connection to sort of hyper feed hive
mind thing and being kind of pushed and
pulled.
So if you've ever been part of what a mob
or if you are on Twitter and you see
people piling on to something and then
you talk to them and they're like, I kind
of blacked out, I don't know what
happened.
Because you can't at this part of the
hierarchy compute the entirety of what
happened.
All you can do is understand sort of your
path that was part of a larger network of
web of paths which themselves, given the
priors of the superstructures you're
embedded in are kind of sort of going
somewhere and represent.
the
error push of all the people that share a
similar type of model that therefore
constitutes a cultural direction.
So thats the best way I think we can
understand hyper-priors as a function of
what it might be like to be a city sort
of thing.
But that's as far as I can take this
metaphor for now.
Daniel: Awesome!
Does anyone want to give a final
thought?
Otherwise, I'll just list just a few
points that I found really cool about the
discussion and kind of places it takes us
at the end.
Anyone else want to give us?
Maxwell: I just want to say that the hard
problem is really hard and it's called
like that for a reason.
I think we're hopefully moving in the
direction of making this less mysterious.
.
But all of this should be taken as very
preliminary investigations, really trying
to sketch out the bare bones of an
explanation.
And yeah, there is far more work ahead of
us than behind us, I think.
Now, any final thoughts?
Mahault: I like to think about it in the
opposite terms.
In terms of the future of evolution can
be understood through what it's like to
have language and what it's like to have
larger scale cognition.
And therefore yes, of course, this is
very preliminary research, but it's cool
to dream.
Daniel: Awesome.
Any guest?
Maria?
Samuel?
Ali? Thales?
Thales: Yeah, quick one.
So any prediction on when the other two
preference will come out?
I'm really interested in it.
Maxwell: Inshallah the Mum paper will be
released early July right now, reasonably,
, and then the other one has to do with
extending outwards and that might be like
another year.
I don't think that's coming soon, but
hopefully revisions to this paper will be
coming out also over the summer and yeah,
I would anticipate July.
Hopefully. We'll see.
There's a lot going on right now!
Daniel: Awesome.
All right Samuel, please.
Samuel: I just want to say thank you to
everyone for answering my questions.
Maxwell: Well, thank you for your
attention, your kind comments and your
interest.
It was really fun to discuss and I think
you asked a lot of important questions.
Daniel: Thales, or anyone else.
Thales: Yeah, I also wanted to thank you
so much for having I mean, I know that
these kinds of discussions can have lots
of implications in many, many other areas,
, but it was really illuminating and
clarifying.
Maxwell: You're too kind, my friend.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, this has been fun. Genuinely!
Daniel: Awesome!
All right, I'll just give a few comments.
.
All right, so first, yes, congratulations
to all for the recent papers.
It's really exciting to see a kind of
continuum and integration with all these
different threads.
The way that we think of physics and the
physics of information and the history
and the philosophy of the physics of
information.
That kind of a gradient might be
reimagined such that there's a clearer
understanding of when it's the firmware
or the kernel of in the tradition of as I
see you at all writing sometimes in
versus interpretations and that's maybe
situational but that's a gray area.
Reminds me of the instrumentalist realism
debates of 2021.
Your with the map and the territory which
has been developed out so much further
and just the ability, especially in a
situation in a model specific way to
separate out the intelligence or
information structure or the behavior
from any kind of qualia type discussion.
The recent developments with Chris Fields
at all and the waste energy and where
free energy goes and the kind of saying
like one has forgotten more than someone
else has learned.
So just the idea that to have awareness,
there has to be that discardle and then
that might be related to the
irreversibility and the time
consciousness that also you've been
developing the Eco Evo devo components
and just multiscale
biology, connecting it to traditions of
thought and work in biology, which is big,
, but that's kind of how we retro
Grandparent back into biology.
Promisingly with the ways that multiscale
systems are already considered and then
also just the recent developments in
category theory and the primacy of the
relational and the physics as information
processing and then the way that that
enables very knowledgeable individuals
like you all to come from a lot of the
philosophy and the history and all these
other threads to come together with the
actual modeling in a very satisfying way.
.
So thank you all for the stream and
really looking forward to next steps.
Bye.
Mahault: Thank you.
Thales: Bye bye.
Thanks.
Bye.